the State Department is condemning
Russia's crackdown on anti-government
protests Russia arrested hundreds of
people yesterday at dozens of
demonstrations this was the largest wave
of anti-government rallies in years
the Kremlin is now rejecting calls to
release him Russia's best known
opposition leader that's Alexei Navalny
was among those detained he made a court
appearance this morning Elizabeth
Palmer's following the developments from
London Elizabeth good morning good
morning well the Kremlin is describing
this big March as a provocation it
wasn't overtly political but it did
manage to unite Russians around one
thing they all agree on and that is how
disgusted they are with official
corruption the demonstrators poured into
central Moscow in an anti-corruption
rally that doubled as a protest against
President Putin but marches like this
need an official permit in Russia or
they're illegal and this one was so with
the demonstrators shouting shame on you
to the government the police moved in
[Applause]
hundreds were arrested including
Alexander Navalny an anti-corruption
campaigner who organized the March
earlier this month he released a video
alleging that Russia's Prime Minister
Dmitry Medvedev had amassed a fortune in
mansions yachts and vineyards through
corrupt deals it went viral and these
protesters are among the millions who
watched it it fueled huge public anger
says CBS radio reporter Alex lund who
himself was arrested at the March it's
rough economic time for the country
right now recession going on so of
course those charges of Whitesburg
widespread corruption by one of the
country's top leaders really struck a
chord with people not only in Moscow
protesters hit the streets across the
country and scuffled with the police
trying to arrest them the resident Putin
is up for re-election next year
widespread discontent like this probably
won't keep him out of power but it is
likely to have him a little worried
especially as Alexander Navalny there
you saw getting arrested has said that
he is going to run against Putin for
president Margaret Liz thank you